翻訳: Natsumi Tsushima
校正: Riaki Poništ
みなさん こんにちは
（観客）こんにちは
みなさんは科学者というと
どんなイメージを持っているでしょうか
例えば
『バック・トゥー・ザ・フューチャー』
のドクとか
あるいは もうちょっと年齢が上の方ですと
御茶ノ水博士とか
まぁ いずれにせよ こんな感じかなぁ
と思うんですけれども
「歳をとっている方」で
「男性」というのが
比較的 科学者のイメージとして
浮かびやすいんじゃないかなと思います
では 女性の科学者というと
どなたを想像するでしょうか
例えば マリー・キュリー夫人 など
浮かびましたかね？
私にとっては自分の母というのが
自分の一番身近な
女性科学者だったわけですけれども
マリー・キュリー夫人 確かに
ノーベル賞を２回も
獲った方という意味では
男性にも珍しい
いないということなので
そういう意味では
本当にすごいんですでれども
ノーベル賞授賞者全体の中で
女性というのはたった5.8％しかいません
881人中の48人という
大変少ない数です
この48人ですけれども
こちらに示すような形なんですけれども
その中で ケミストリー 化学
それからフィジックス 物理
そしてフィジオロジー・アンド・メディスン
医学 生理学 こちらの受賞者というのは
たった17人しかいません
マリー・キュリーが２回獲っているので
18回なんですけれども17人
つまり 残りの30名ほどは
科学ではでないということですね
では 一体なぜ 女性の科学者というのは
少ないのでしょうか
女性は科学に向いていないというような
適性の違いがあるのでしょうか
このことについて
少し考えてみたいと思います
もちろん私たちは
人間を含めた生き物というものは
哺乳類では有性生殖を行うという
生物的な差がありまして
こちらに大きい方のX染色体
それから小さい方の
Y染色体がありますけれども
性の差というのは
このY染色体を持っているかどうか
こちらで決まってきます
でも こういった性の差があるのは
なぜかというと
これは実は非常に強い—
ロバストな
ダイバーシティを生み出す
戦略だったんですね
なので私たち ヒトを含む哺乳類というのは
こういった有性生殖を行いますけれども
そのことによって
地球上で非常に繁栄することができた
ということになります
このような 生物学的性差というものが
徐々に［発生して］
私たちの体の中で
違うホルモンができる
そして 例えば脳のつくりというのも
ほんのちょっと男女の差があります
例えばここの論文からとったものでは
女性の方が脳の左右の
コネクションが強いというような
そういう傾向がありますよ
ということを
論文から取って来ていますけれども
このような脳の違いというのは
私たちがどのように世界を認識するか
どのように考えるかということにも
影響を与えることがあります
例えば 『地図の読めない女』という
本のタイトルがあったのを
覚えてらっしゃるでしょうか
場所 道順を覚えるということにおいて
地図的な物の考え方というのも
ありますけれども
でも例えば私の場合ですと
あそこの交差点の角に
お花屋さんがあって そこを右に曲がって
そういったことを繰り返していって
ゴールにたどり着くことができる
だから もしゴールに辿り着く
ということが目的であれば
違った考え方を通って
ゴールにたどり着いてもいいわけですよね
さて
このような生物学的な性差の他に
社会学的な性差というのがあります
これは「ジェンダー」
というふうに言いますけれども
例えば女性だったらスカートを着る—
私は今日はワンピースですけれども
男性だったらズボンを履く
女性の場合 最近は
ズボンを履く方も多いですね
こういった服装の違いだけではなくて
例えば「男性は外に出て働きましょう
女性は家庭にこもって
家のことをしましょう」というような
性別役割分担になってしまったとしたら
これはちょっと問題ではないかな
というふうに考えられます
で このような社会的な性差というのは
一体いつ頃から生まれてくるのか
ということに関して
かなり若い時あるいは小さい時からの
刷り込みというのがあると考えられます
例えば 子供がおもちゃで遊ぶ時に
一般的に男の子が車のおもちゃで遊んで
女の子はお人形さんで遊ぶ
このお人形さんの場合は
リカちゃんというお名前が
付いているんですけれども
リカちゃんという名前なんですが
「メルシー！　絵日記は
算数の宿題よりずっと楽しいわ」
あるいは「そっか リカ算数は苦手だけど
頑張ってみるね」というような感じで
リカ（理科）ちゃんなんですけれども
理系は苦手という設定だったりする
こういったことで
小さい時から「可愛い女の子は
理科が苦手 算数が苦手」というような
刷り込みができてしまう
というようなこともありますね
で さらに いろんな形で
親からあるいは先生から
いろんな刷り込みがあります
例えばお父さんが
「お前理系に進学して
就職先なんてあるのかなぁ」とか
あるいはお母さんが
「え そんなことしたら あなた
お嫁の貰い手がなくなっちゃうかも
しれないじゃない」とか
そんなふうなことを受けるということが
あるかもしれません
でも中学２年生の時点で
世界的な統計では
男女で—男の子 女の子で
数学や理科の平均点の差というのは
実はないんですね
にも関わらず
大学に進学する時点では
日本では
男性が３対女性が１というような形に
なってしまう
また 女性の中にはバリバリと仕事をする
これは かならずしも
科学者だけではないですけれども
そういうことをすると 例えば
家庭とそれから仕事を
両立させるということが
難しいんではないかというふうに
心配になる人もいるかもしれません
確かに 出産ということは
女性しかできない とても大事な
役割だと思いますけれども
例えば 子供を育てる あるいは
家庭の中のことをするというのは
男性ができない
その能力がないわけではないですよね
ですので
こういったことは改善できるんではないかな
というふうに思うんですけど
さてそうやって社会的な性差などを
刷り込まれていく間に
例えば キャリア志向に関しての
ジェンダー差というのが生まれます
これは 自然科学系の学会 学協会で行なった
２万人規模のアンケート
なんですけれども
「あなたは将来キャリアとして
例えば教授のようになって
研究室を主宰したいですか
PIになりたいですか」という答え
そして
「PIじゃなくてもいいから
研究を続けたい」という答え
女性ですと これ大体半々
同じぐらいの割合なんですけれども
同じ問いに対して
男性はこういうふうに答えます
60％ぐらいの方は「自分は最終的に
研究室を主宰する教授になりたい」
16％ぐらいは「そうではない」
これは女性のほうがある意味
教授のポジションというのは
そんだけないわけですから
現実的な考え方をするということでも
あるかもしれませんし
男性はものすごくポジティブシンキングだ
ということなのかもしれません
でも 結果としてですね
これはどういうことかというと
もしかしたら より優秀かもしれない女性が
キャリアを諦めて
もしかしたら 女性よりも
優秀ではない男性に
そのポジションを
取られてしまっているかもしれない
ということで
我が国においてこれは
人材が生かされてないんではないか
というふうに考えられるわけです
で これは某企業の例ですけれども
業績が悪くなった時に
それをリカバーするために
ダイバーシティが大切である
ということで成功した
そういった女性の参画 あるいは
多様な人たちが参画するということが
非常に重要なんではないか
というふうに考えられます
では 私からここで ３つのメッセージを
伝えたいと思うんですけれども
１つめですけれども まず
無意識のバイアスに気づくということです
それは いろんなバイアスがあります
男性にも女性にもあります
例えば子供が
保育園に行っていて 熱が出たと
で その時に お父さんが
迎えに行かなきゃってことになると
上司の人が例えば
「え 君が保育園に迎えにいくの？」と
あるいはリーダーというと
つい男性のイメージを持っているので
「リーダーに適した女性が
いないんだよね」と
そんなふうに思ってしまうようなことが
あるかもしれません
あるいは女性のほうにも
私はこれを「白馬の王子様症候群」と
名付けているんですけれども
ちょっと笑ってもらえましたね はい
（笑）
例えば 女性は
自分が優秀だったらば
「誰かが私のことを
いいポジションに引き上げてくれる
だから 私待ってる」
という間に 実はそのポジションは
誰か ポジティブシンキングな男性に
取られてしまうかもしれない
ということがありますよね
なのでもっと自分で手を挙げる
ということをした方がいいかもしれない
そして ２つめですけれども
メンターを持つ
ロールモデルを持つということですが
私にとっては それは両親でしたし
指導教員にも非常に助けられましたけれども
東北大学の例ですけれども
最初に日本で初めて女子学生の
入学を受け入れたという
輝かしい伝統があるわけですが
その３人は 化学だったり
数学だったりしました
これは どういう人たちに
助けられたかというと
初代総長がオープンドアポリシー
門戸開放ということを言った
そして だったらあなたも入れますよと
入学をエンカレッジした長井先生
そして さらに大学に入学した後に
大学院にも進学したらどうですか
と言ってさらにエンカレッジした真島先生
こういった男性のメンターもいたから
ということがあります
ですので 男性も女性も
ぜひ女性をエンカレッジして
いただけたらいいなと私は思います
最後 ３つめですけれども
それは 今日のテーマにも関わりますけれども
ネットワーキングということです
東北大学 女性の割合
非常に少ないですけれども—
大学院生でも
４分の１しかいませんが—
私はこの東北大学に
サイエンスエンジェル制度
というものを作りました
これは自然科学系の女性の大学院生が
手を挙げて
そして総長から任命されて
身近なロールモデルとして
科学の面白さ楽しさを
みんなに伝えるという役割を
ミッションを担っています
例えばオープンキャンパスに出たり
出張セミナーをしたり
あるいはここの
カタールサイエンスホールでも行う
サイエンスイベントに参加する
そういったことで
東北大学のサイエンスエンジェルさんたちが
こういうイベントを行う間に
ネットワークを作り
それをずっと持ち続けてもらえたらいいなぁ
というふうに思っています
最後に私の大好きな言葉を
ご紹介したいというふうに思います
これはフランスの化学者であり
生物学者でもあった—
ルイ・パスツールという方の
言葉なんですけれども
科学に国境はない
という言葉を残しています
日本語はこの後さらに続く—
「だが 科学者には祖国がある」
という言葉とセットになっています
科学はボーダーレスなんだけれども
それぞれの科学者に
自分の大事な文化があり言葉がある
ということを大事にした方がいい
ということなんですけれども
これを私は今日はこういう言い方に
変えたいと思います
科学に性差はない
男性がやっても
女性がやってもいいことです
でも 科学者にはジェンダーがある
それは 異なる視点を持った女性研究者が
もっと科学に参画するということが
科学の進展やイノベーションの鍵に
なるのではないかというふうに考えるからです
（英語）女性には科学が必要で
科学にも女性が必要である
どうもありがとうございました
（拍手）